هناك أمان في الأرقام ،
لكن واحدة من غواناكو
لم تحصل على المذكرة التي
يجب أن تقترب منها ماما بوما قدر
الإمكان
[موسيقى]
آه لقد
قفزت إلى البندقية ،
واحد فقط من كل خمسة من عمليات صيد واناكو الخاصة بها
هو
وقت ناجح للاستلقاء
على وجبتها التالية يجب أن تتجول  في وقت قريب
، تم لعب لعبة الغميضة المميتة هذه
لآلاف السنين عندما تكون حواس العم
حادة وتسمح لهم أرجلهم الطويلة بالركض
بسرعة 35 ميلاً في الساعة
تقريبًا مثل لعبة بوما
ولكن هناك الكثير من الفرائس البطيئة حول
[الموسيقى]
أكثر من 10 ملايين رأس من الأغنام ترعى الأغنام في
الأراضي العشبية في باتاغونيا
والتي عادة ما تكون محمية من قبل
الراوشوس مثل ميركو
أوتروفيسيك إذا كان البوما يرمز إلى الأماكن البرية في المنطقة ،
فإن مربي الماشية مثل ميركو
هم الذين يجسدون روحها الحدودية
[الموسيقى]
ولكن هذين الرمزين الباتاغونيين
كان لهما  قضايا
[موسيقى]
ميركو ليس غاوتشو عاديًا ،
إنه كاسادور دي ليون ماهر
، صياد أسد ،
إنه الرجل الذي توظفه عندما
تواجه مشكلة في لعبة بوما